the Supreme Court May finally be closing
in on the infamous leaker remember the
leaker who leaked the draft of the
decision that ultimately overturned Roe
v Wade and ended the constitutional
right to an abortion the Supreme Court
according to the Wall Street Journal has
narrowed their search down to a small
number of suspects now if you had to
guess is the perpetrator a right-winger
or a left Winger let me know what you
think in the comments I am still leaning
towards right winger for reasons I've
talked about before primarily that it
seems to me that they would be most
incentivized to do the leaking thinking
if I leak the fact that they're looking
at a vote that would overturn Roe v Wade
the justices will feel self-conscious
about changing their vote